[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
up piers morgan uncensored tonight putin
again ramps up his nuclear threat
russian sports star should they be
banned from wimbledon and former
president trump serves his own volley
it's at me again but first it's my brain
dump
as vladimir putin butchers ukraine
millions of ordinary russians are forced
for the daily diet of six propaganda to
convince him of his warped alternative
reality and there's no such thing as a
free press to tell the truth or hold
into account putin's russia is a country
where journalists are routinely murdered
literally thrown out of windows
reporting the facts they face 15 years
in jail for criticizing his evil war or
the special military operation as he so
disingenuously calls it
here in our free world brave journalists
are risking their lives daily so that we
know exactly what is going on in ukraine
where the barbaric dictator is waging
genocide in a democratic sovereign
country
in putin's russia even his closest
allies had a football field away from
their slayer in chief
but here in our free world comedians can
sit a few meters away from the president
of the united states hurling zingers at
him as if he was the groom at a wedding
you know i was a little confused about
why me
but then i was told that you get your
highest approval ratings when a biracial
african guy is standing next to you so
uh
so let me just say uh joe
i'm glad that i could do my part
i think ever since you've come into
office things are really looking up you
know gas is up rent is up food is up
everything this is truly the golden era
of conspiracy theories
whether it's the right wing believing
trump can still win the 2020 election or
the left believing joe biden can still
win the 2024 election
well that was trevor noah at the white
house correspondents dinner at an annual
event in washington but journalists who
spend their lives scrutinizing and
criticizing the president of the united
states without fear of being killed and
amid the glamour the black tie and the
comedy there was a very serious point
here and noah made it rather beautifully
in america you have the right
to seek the truth and speak the truth
even if it makes people in power
uncomfortable even if it makes your
viewers or your readers uncomfortable
you understand how amazing that is
i stood here tonight and i made fun of
the president of the united states and
i'm gonna be fine
i'm gonna be fine right
can you ever imagine putin president g
in china or north korea's kim jong-un
attending a celebration for journalists
whose job it is to shine a light on
their incompetence or allowing
themselves to be publicly ridiculed on
national television we all know what
would happen to a tv star like trevor
noah who dare make jokes like that at
their expense in those oppressive
totalitarian regimes and that's why we
should never take any of our freedoms
for granted and that's why this couldn't
have come at a more as a more timely
reminder of how important it is to live
in a country with a free press and
freedom of speech
well just as mere tough talk and
sanctions won't end this war we can't
defeat putin the demon by demonizing
ordinary russians
tennis stars from russia and belarus are
barred from competing at the wimbledon
grand slam tournament this year over the
ukraine invasion it means that two of
the top 10 best men's players in the
world won't be at the world's premier
tennis competition but despite both of
them courageously speaking out against
the war and calling for peace
well tennis superstars like novak
djokovic andy murray and rafa nadal have
now criticized the ban and i agree with
them
i think it is very unfair for my russian
mates my colleagues in that sense poor
them there's not much they can do
poor them at the end of the day it is
not their fault what is happening in
this moment with the wall
first off it's reeks of hypocrisy did
wimbledon ban stan smith jimmy connors
or john mcenroe during the wildly
unpopular wars waged by america in
vietnam iraq or afghanistan of course
they didn't and what about the ill-fated
and what many of you is a legal invasion
of iraq by the us and uk
andre agassi andy roddick and serena
williams all won tennis grand slams in
2003 applying this new logic they'd have
been banned from taking part there's
also been no clamor to ban saudi arabian
athletes over their country's bloody war
in yemen which is no less reprehensible
than russia's war in ukraine
in fact saudi arabia hosted a formula
one grand prix just a few weeks ago and
its athletes compete in the olympics
i fully support blocking russian
national teams who represent the russian
state under the russian flag but
targeting the country's individuals for
blame over the behavior of their
despotic leader doesn't make sense and
is part of a worrying trend
we've seen russian sports stars heckled
russian arts being cancelled around the
world russian products being boycotted
even stupidly some of the sound russian
russian restaurants blacklisted even
though some of them are run by
ukrainians the city of oxford even
daubed over this sign because it used to
be partnered with perm in russia this is
all pointless tokenism it won't work and
it hurts the wrong people dictators
depend on stoking fear and hatred of the
outside world this is all just
ammunition for putin's propaganda drive
cancelling russian sport and culture
won't win this war
well speaking of alternative realities
the conservative mp caught watching porn
in the house of commons keeping global
embarrassment on britain's democracy has
fallen on his sword no pun intended
sadly it wasn't without one last blast
of cringe-worthy squirming neil parish
who's also a farmer first brazenly
called for an investigation of the
allegations allowing rumors to swirl
about his own colleagues when he knew
he'd done it and he tried to explain it
all the way with an excuse was frankly
utterly ridiculous
the uh situation was that that um i um
apparently enough it was tractors i was
looking at and um so i did get into
another website that had a very similar
name
um and i watched it for a bit which i
shouldn't have done
who hasn't stumbled across porn looking
for tractors
it gets worse paris later brief
specifically he was searching
for dominator combine harvesters
when a rather different kind of
dominator popped up
but there is a pathway to redemption for
hapless parish and it comes in this form
of his former conservative colleague
brooks newmark you may not remember the
name and new mark quit as a british
government minister in 2014 after
newspapers exposed him by sending lewd
photos to a reporter posing as a young
female fan
for years after we never really heard
anything about him again but now it's
emerged that new mark has risked his
life to almost single-handedly save over
seven and a half thousand ukrainian
women and children in the past two
months helping them evacuate the war
zone he raised three hundred thousand
dollars from friends and family to begin
a bus service taking refugees out of
ukraine
from sinner to savior
good for him
now i don't believe in cancer culture so
i was obviously distraught to learn that
the woman who canceled me
has now herself been cancelled
yes netflix has shelved the development
of pearl an animated series created by
meghan markle with sir elton john's
husband david furnish about a 12 year
old girl inspired by influential women
apparently was based on her own very
inspiring rags to royal rich's story but
sadly it seems nobody at netflix shared
my inspiration
the streaming giant reported very bad
results last week a direct consequence
some critics say they're increasingly
tedious woke output including a new
series about a pregnant man
netflix stock tanks so they've had to
pull the plug on megan's vanity project
to cut costs and concern is now mounting
that the duke and duchess of netflix's
whole hundred million dollar deal with
the company may now be in jeopardy
none of this brings me any pleasure
especially after the sad failure of her
nauseatingly patronizing children's book
the bench
but it would be remiss of me not to just
politely suggest that megan and harry
may be suddenly discovering that maybe
the rest of the world isn't quite as
excited by their self-righteous brand of
pious hypocritical money-grabbing virtue
singing world bashing as they are
because let's face it when the world's
wokest production company axes the
world's wokest project by the world's
wokest celebrity that's a whole new
level of humiliation i wish megan
sincerely all the very best at this
difficult time
russian state television have issued a
brazen warning that moscow could wipe
out britain with a nuclear tsunami in
retaliation for supporting ukraine
declaring there would be no survivors
in britain they seem to be rambling why
did they threaten vast russia with
nuclear weapons while they are only a
small island why do they play games
another option is to plunge britain into
the depths of the sea using russian
underwater robotic drone poseidon the
explosion of his torpedo close to
britain's shores will raise a giant wave
a tsunami up to 500 meters this tidal
wave is also a carrier of extremely high
doses of radiation surging over britain
it will turn what is left of them into
radioactive desert
well retired four star general a former
vice chief of staff of the u.s army
general jack team joins me as does
tobias hell with conservative mp and
former defense minister welcome to both
of you a general king first of all great
honor to have you on the show thank you
very much for for joining uh peter
morgan censored
when you hear that kind of rhetoric
from the russians and we're hearing more
and more of this now
it is pretty sobering listening isn't it
it's frankly quite terrifying to many
people
when i interviewed president trump
earlier this week he felt that america
in particular should be using more
bellicose rhetoric back reminding them
the russians that america has just as
many nukes as they do what is your view
well the fact is uh we have a very
effective strategic terrance about the
kind of
warfare that's being threatened here
which is
global nuclear warfare and that that
kind of language is absolutely
horrendous and certainly outrageous to
do that i don't think we have to walk up
the nuclear escalation with them but we
remind them
that there is a significant strategic
deterrence here among the united states
britain and france
and certainly the destruction of their
entire country and population is what
they're putting at risk here
i think they clearly understand that i
think this is mostly trying to rattle
your population as well as mine and also
impact our our leaders
um
i think uh what's really troubling to
them
is the unanimity that the eu and nato
has
really defined here not just in in
getting better sanctions and improved
sanctions but most significantly
is the arms and ammunition that we're
providing to the ukrainians and
certainly
the backdrop here appears is the fact
that the russians have largely been
failing and even in this much smaller
offensive that they're conducting right
now
they haven't made much gains and
last 24 36 hours they haven't been doing
much
much of anything so
yes uh there is saber rattling going on
here uh for sure now the issue with a
tactical nuclear weapon i think that
gives us all a little bit more concern
that something like that could be used
i really believe the biden
administration could be much stronger
about what our response should be here
both publicly and privately and i will
say this i do think that some of this
rattling is going on particularly as it
concerns the biden administration
appears because
the binding administration set the tone
here very early on march 21
70 000 troops show up on the ukraine
border 60 days into the biden
administration's reign right after the
inauguration it's no accident i'm
absolutely convinced
uh putin is doing that to test this
administration which he believed would
be weak
and there's an opportunity okay the
trump administration had a scheduled
deployment of
arms and munitions in march of that year
planned
by administration did not execute it and
publicly stated the reason yeah they did
not want to provoke putin yeah
i felt that one of the things that may
have empowered vladimir putin uh to go
into ukraine and president trump said
the same thing was the very uh
candid if not catastrophic withdrawal of
forces from afghanistan that that looked
like it was america in a form of
surrender what did you what did you
think of that what do you think of where
we are with this war and actually what
does defeat look like now for putin
well these are all great questions
firstly good to see uh general keane uh
plea pleased to share a platform with
him but yes uh i think putin has seen
that over 30 years in fact the west has
become quite timid and our humiliation
in departing from afghanistan i think
was the ice another cake that was the
moment that he intended to strike and we
need to wake up that we are actually
witnessing a turning point in our
history this isn't just about ukraine
this is much much bigger this is about
putin taking advantage of complacency
over 30 years as we've withdrawn back on
our military capabilities
uh putin is very much now alignment with
uh president xi with china and russia
forming an access and leveraging our
timidity what we're seeing at the moment
though is an invisible invasion as
general keane just implied
in contrast incredible uh resilience and
heroism from uh the ukrainian forces
themselves but we haven't leveraged that
you know russia's ineptitude caught the
west off guard remember the u.s even
offered to uh zaninski a helicopter
flight out that's how they thought uh
how competent they thought russian
forces would be but here we are ukraine
doing an incredible job russia having to
back away from kiev move around to
donbass that is the moment when they're
regrouping rearming they're starting to
redeploy that's when you launch a
counter attack but where is the west
where is nato to leverage that the big
question i pose to the west indeed to
britain and the united states is what is
our objection what are we trying to
achieve in ukraine is it to support
ukrainians to push russia completely out
of mainland ukraine or are we content
with some form of stalemate occurring
over don bass we need to clarify exactly
what let me know
okay i mean look these are good
questions let me ask general keane those
questions what what do you think the
west's objective is
right now and let me ask you also
general kim
what is defeat for putin and what is
victory now do we think
well first of all
i think we're very ambiguous about what
our intent there is we started out by
just arming the ukrainians certainly
to likely
deal with an insurgency because they
most people felt the regime was going to
be collapsed
and then certainly the ukrainians
responded very positively
russians responded very incompetently
and huge opportunity arose it took the
biden administration far too long to
make that transition
and get them the weapons they needed and
finally we're there we are clearly doing
that i think the meeting that was held
in ramstein where 40 nations showed up
14 of them not european uh with
secretary of defense alston and chairman
of joint chiefs the united states miley
that is significant and what we have to
do is continue that
in terms of the objective the objective
was never clear from the beginning but
now has come come much more into focus
the secretary of state the secretary of
defense the chairman the joint chiefs
others in the administration even
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi is
talking about victory here defeating the
russian military inside of ukraine which
is i believe is should be our objective
it should have been on our objective and
unequivocally clearly stated from the
beginning and it's certainly when you
when you have ambiguity like that
it actually leverages our our enemy
russia to be sure because they're not
certain about
what what we're driving towards and
that's why i think they've been
surprised by the level of effort
recently i i think
there still is opportunity here for that
objective to be achieved and we've got
to double down and continue to robust
support that we're providing the
ukrainians plus the the moral support
that they need as well john mccain great
to talk to you tomorrow thank you very
much too really appreciate it
on censor next a mega blow for megan the
duchess of sussex has had her next show
cancelled can she still justify our 100
million deal that's coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to piers morgan on sensor
now there were two nailed on celebrity
certainties once war broke out in
ukraine the first was that angelina
jolie would at some stage fly over there
to make it all about herself posing for
numerous selfies with her adoring fans
fortunately some of the ukrainian youth
didn't get the angie pr op memo look at
the guy there with these headphones
is completely ignoring it fantastic
the second of course was madonna
deciding that what we all need to cheer
ourselves up in these dark times was her
doing this on stage in colombia
[Music]
this did actually cheer me up it did
bring a smile to my face just not i
suspect for the reasons that she hoped
well joining me now is a veteran
journalist attorney fox news host uh
legend actually arrived haralda what a
joy to have you on my new show thank you
so much for joining us
pierce my pleasure we haven't seen each
other since uh donald trump's celebrity
apprentice in 2015. that's completely
true and in fact why don't we start with
trump because i was going to ask you
about my interview which is obviously
ricocheted around the world it's
attracted three trump statements so far
of increasing what venom and humor
actually uh basically saying the
interview was terrible brilliant great
for ratings i'm a loser i'm finished and
washed up and then there was this clip
last night from his uh this was his
appearance at a rally
uh where he said this
think it's coming
is it coming
you know we'll come to the clip in a
moment a rather the point i was gonna
make he says in the clip that i've gone
crazy
uh we got it we've got it i'm sorry
we're going to play now
this crazy pierce morgan did you see
that show
piers morgan thank you sir piers morgan
show you see piers morgan he sort of had
it i think piers is
over the hill
he opened the show with an interview of
me i did him a favor i didn't want to do
a stupid show it's on
fox nation what is fox nation what is it
they're going to love me when i say what
is fox it's on fox nation he opened with
great ratings when he did me and then
after my interview was finished he
bombed and he's now down over 70 percent
and
maybe they'll someday learn that
maybe they should hire me as an anchor
should i go to work and say we'll get
that greatest reading
we'll sit there and we'll riff
i've got to say herrera i would watch
donald trump if he did anchor a show
like this i mean i would him live and
unfiltered every night would be
fantastic i doubt he's gonna do it but
what was that i mean i just felt that
it's a massive overreaction by donald
trump to what was actually when you
watched it a really insightful revealing
interview which most people i know saw
it actually thought he came out of it
pretty well
i i saw it and that was the conclusion i
had piers a pretty good interview he
asked all the right questions the
necessary questions but as you know he
has
profoundly thin skin
he doesn't
suffer insults lightly he
has a rule you hit him he'll hit you
back
even if you didn't intend to hit him by
even asking a question that he viewed as
vaguely uh you know impolite uh he he
carries that grudge
forever until there's some something
else like jd vance the candidate here in
the state of ohio uh running for senate
has just been endorsed by trump despite
the fact that he called trump everything
from
all right no i've got no doubt
everything he's got
imbecile and everything else
i've got no doubt i'll be i'll be happy
with that okay but i'm going to ask you
two questions really about it
which i think everyone is wondering
do you think trump will run again
because tucker carlson earlier last week
on the show doesn't think he will uh and
secondly would it be a good thing for
america given how divisive and
polarizing he was in those four years
albeit not unsuccessful in many ways
either would it be a good thing if he
did
i think president trump really wants to
be president again
you know i've known him since 1976
i've i've never seen him shirk from a
challenge
i believe that he's really hurt by the
results the legitimate results of the
november 2020 election
you know he's egotistical he wants to be
back in the white house it's not that
he's deprived of helicopters or or huge
uh jumbo private jets it's just his ego
has been rattled and he has it's it's a
grudge it's a grudge now uh you know
with the democratic party he wants to be
back in the white house to evict them
now will he win i i don't know he'd have
some real hurdles to clear not the least
of which is that he's lost voters like
me in the middle who supported him you
know pretty strongly until he decided
not to abide by the constitution of the
united states so he has that hurdle but
you know the republicans have enforced
amnesia
they uh they've decided that not to
remember january 6 or the rest of it uh
so i think that he may unless
ron desantis the the florida governor
who's gaining momentum here uh you know
decides to make a go of it
and uh trump lives in florida he may i
don't know it i'm not sure how that
dynamic works the answer your question
is
i think he probably will run
and do i think that's good for america i
i don't think that he will win i think
that there's too much baggage so i know
that that's a dodge of your question
because i just don't know the answer for
instance in ukraine what would have
happened if trump were president when
putin was rattling the sabers and
mobilizing his army would trump have
reacted differently he was friends with
putin maybe it never would have come to
an invasion but maybe
just maybe when he called the invasion
savvy and uh was the other word genius
uh that that uh he would have kind of
let russia take ukraine back i i don't
know the answer to that
we just had the white house
correspondents dinner i've attended that
a few times uh you only been many times
i know we've got a little highlights
reel here it's a fun night let's have a
look
this is the first time
president attended this dinner in six
years
it's understandable
we had a horrible plague
followed by two years of covet
if my predecessor came to this dinner
this year
now that
would really have been a real coup in
america you have the right
to seek the truth and speak the truth
even if it makes people in power
uncomfortable even if it makes your
viewers or your readers uncomfortable i
stood here tonight and i made fun of the
president of the united states
and i'm going to be fine
i'm going to be fine right
i thought that was a very powerful
conclusion there by trevor noah i think
he had a good night all rounders she's
singing everybody
but i thought the speech he made at the
end there about the importance of free
speech and his ability to do zingers at
joe biden's expense which would never be
tolerated in a totalitarian country and
a powerful impact i thought
well he said all the right things to a
very receptive audience i was there in
2011 one of the many times that i have
been at the washington correspondence
dinner when donald trump was in the
audience and president obama just mocked
him ruthlessly saying that he was ready
because he had to choose between
meatloaf and
some other obscure
uh sea lister
to who had the hot tub in front of the
white house
trump was outraged by that i i am
convinced that that was the night trump
decided he was going to run i think
you're right for president of the united
states he was going to show them it's
it's it's again it's that uh you know
it's that uh same you're seeing it in
miniature yeah you know the way he
reacts to those kinds of challenges and
i think that that put him over the top
then he decided i'm going to show obama
i'm going to show everybody i'm going to
run for president i'm going to win
you've covered a lot of war zones in
your time very courageously errata what
do you make of ukraine we had a debate
earlier about the the nuclear saber
rattling they're doing constantly now
but the scenes that we're seeing we're
sort of living this war in real time on
social media like we've never lived a
war before
how does this all play out do you think
i think just in that last point
social media now people with iphones are
doing as good a job as i did with two
tons of satellite equipment it is
extraordinary and the bravery uh uh
our our benjamin hall uh who lost his
leg has lost his his crew uh it's so
dangerous it's such it's heavy combat uh
you know i i
so admire the coverage now in terms of
how this all plays out and where it goes
and i heard your uh interview with
general keane
how it ends i have no idea but the
nuclear saber rattling has rattled me as
a child of the 1950s who used to duck
under our desks at school
you know in nuclear drills that would
have been fruitless who lived through as
a as a cadet in maritime college the
1962 cuban missile crisis this is the
worst it's been since then yeah you know
this is you know people have to
understand that when people are talking
about nuclear use of nuclear weapons
you know in a way that it is
plausible if remote it is
unnerving to me it is absolutely so
profoundly distressing uh to think that
these world leaders would actively be
considerate now what the word is now
that putin is going to use a tactical
tactical nuclear weapon to explode over
the black sea or some unpopulated area
uh in uh in in in ukraine some place uh
you know as a demonstration that's
that's insanity it's insanity it is
ridiculous
mutual assured destruction is what
nuclear warfare is all about and it's
just so distressing to me that uh that
that world leaders even someone as as
nutty as putin is showing himself to be
would be
putting the world's very survival uh in
play
for what for what exactly for dunbas for
uh you know some little
shaving of eastern ukraine what exactly
is it that putin is so you know so angry
about that he would he would end the
world i i had a history professor very
briefly mr fabregas in social studies
who who told me that he had no doubt but
that hitler at the end of the war if he
had a choice and there was a button that
said end the world
because we're losing or not hitler would
have pushed the button it would have
ended the world i remember how upset i
was by that is this the same thing is
putin now playing with the button
because uh he may lose this ridiculous
stupid war and bravo to ukraine bravo to
zielinski
they're kicking butt at great cost but
they they threw the world's second most
powerful or third most powerful army out
of the region around the capital and now
uh putin is trying to pick up the pieces
in the east side uh you know i i think
that this is horrible what's going on
with putin and bravo to ukraine and the
western allies you know that's one thing
about trump i don't know would trump had
have held nato together with with the uk
and er would he have would he have held
them together to have a united front
against putin he hated nato half of nato
wasn't paying the two percent he he he
he was so disparaging of them and it
sounded like he wanted the atlantic
alliance gone that he didn't even think
the united states should be in the in
the in nato you know what if there was
no nato now yeah you know i i think that
uh there's so many so many interrelated
questions as always radha brilliantly uh
brilliantly observed from all your
experience i was going to throw you a
question about
the duke and duchess of sussex but
frankly it feels almost an insult to ask
you something so pathetically trivial
after what you have it's not really
because i thought
i followed prince harry into
helmut province in afghanistan i missed
him by a week but all the american gi's
were singing his praises you know you
know he he's kind of drifted away from
that but he was a hero in 2008 i'd love
that guy back you know my brother-in-law
actually my sister's husband he taught
harry and william at sandhurst military
academy uh he was in charge of their
training and i think we'd love to see
that harry back around it great to talk
to you thank you so much for coming on
okay pierce thank you
uncensored next djokovic murray and
nadal have all attacked lombard's
decision to ban russian and belarusian
athletes from this year's tournament
i'll speak to tennis legend
over what's next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to peterborough and
uncensored rafa nadal says wimbledon is
bad on russian players at wimbledon is
unfair
or so against koski retired from tennis
in january he's now taking up arms to
protect his homeland in ukraine he took
to twitter to say
rafa nadal we competed together we
played each other on tour please tell me
how it's unfair oh it's fair that
ukrainian players cannot return home how
is it fair the ukrainian kids cannot
play tennis how is it fair that
ukrainians are dying and sergey joins me
and now along with legend and nine-time
wimbledon winner martinez welcome to
both of you sega let me start with you
that was a powerful tweet
and there's no doubt when you read that
tweet
and you think about someone like
yourself who played tennis competitively
for ukraine for many years and has now
gone back and has now joined the battle
against putin and and his genocidal
rampage there's no doubt everybody i'm
sure will feel huge empathy with you the
question becomes i guess
that where where do you take the
argument if individuals
rather than nations rather than teams
for example if individuals get punished
for the for the behavior of their
leaders
then you could end up with a lot of
people getting banned year in year out
all sorts of reasons
surely they can but unfortunately uh the
regime in russia created a
delusional reality for russians
and the top athletes they have that
reach they have that uh audition for
their fans and they could tell them
what's really going on
and honestly if the russian players and
bearish players would come out and say
publicly they condemned the invasion
that they would really say they're
against the war
there'll be something you know everybody
would then consider about benny but
they're staying silent uh saying no war
means if ukraine will stop shooting the
war would be over but it's not true if
you can't stop shooting there'll be no
more ukraine and normal ukrainians
so the question here is it's not about
whether it is good to ban somebody or
not it's a question whether it's normal
to stay neutral when your country is
killing innocent people okay well
martina it's obviously that's not normal
obviously it's disgusting i think we all
agree with that but it's really about i
guess the precedent that's being set
here and i i raised the point earlier at
the top of the show that if you had the
same kind of logic for example you know
after the vietnam war after the uh
what many think was the illegal invasion
of iraq for example then a lot of
american stars would be banned from
tournaments that they ended up winning
what is your view about this
well first i want to say sergey
bravo to you uh my hat is off uh i you
are just so brave to be doing what
you're doing truly uh unbelievable
as for the players as you say it could
be a slippery slope i
because what is the option for the
russian and belarusian players uh if
they support the war i mean i'd say if
they support uh poutine obviously
openly they should not be allowed to
play but if they go against it what does
that have what happens to them what
happens to their families etc they would
literally be forced to defect
uh in order to play tennis and i think
you're making a very unfair situation
obviously horrible situation ukraine
you're making it worse by doing this i
think the players who did not support
putin who actually have spoken out
against the war like probably shinkova
has openly spoke about it i think rublev
wrote not no to war on the on the camera
after a match
it's such a fine line to walk if you're
from those countries and there is no
good way out of it um so my heart goes
out to everybody involved in this but if
the only option is for these players to
leave their country so they can play
tennis i think that's that's unfair as
well sergey i mean the president i would
i would say immediately this brings to
mind is
saudi arabia's war mongering in yemen
for example hasn't led to a ban on saudi
competitors for example at the olympics
uh it hasn't stopped them hosting a
formula one grand prix race
so there's a lot of hypocrisy here isn't
there about the way that we
we view conflicts around the world and
how we punish people
surely there is but let's say saudi
arabia doesn't possess any nuclear
weapons and saudi arabian
kings do not threat europe with
airstrikes saying that the missile will
land in london within 200 seconds it's
let him believe in 160 seconds on a
mainstream tv with your anchors saying
these words and lines
so it's pretty different situation i
would say
when you're preparing your nation which
is russia to basically say that there's
no world without russia in it so they
are preparing the nation if they are
going to lose the war in ukraine that
they're ready to end the world
is that something everybody should
consider
[Music]
i mean i i've got to be honest with you
i i think martina it's a very
complicated issue i actually thought
long and hard over the last day or so
about what i thought about this once i
heard about this ban from wimbledon i
understand that wimbledon for example
they're really doing it at the behest of
the british government and the heavy
sanctions they brought in they're sort
of taking their lead from the government
um which some people might think is is a
bit cowardly of them to stand behind the
government but i can understand them
taking the lead in that way and they
wanted to avoid uh it's been reported
the potential spectacle of the men's
tournament being won by a russian
competitor and and for example the
duchess of cambridge
who's the patron of wimbledon tennis
presenting him with an award of giving
putin a massive propaganda prize i mean
this is the the problem isn't it if you
do allow them to compete and they win
putin gets his moment on the world stage
absolutely and that's why we should not
have been rewarding these horrible
countries with international
competitions whether it's the olympics
in china the world cup in qatar world
cup in russia etc saudi arabia having
the as you said the f1 races so it
legitimizes these uh these uh
governments and that that's not right on
the other hand tennis is a very
individual sport but it's like it's a
normal situation i know if i was living
in russia right now i would probably be
moving my family out as are many people
that can leave the country because it's
just such a disaster and what they're
doing is so so wrong but it is just
sad that it would have to come to that
but i think if i were if i were living
there i would probably be doing that but
uh yeah there's no way of winning this
one way or the other and the loss of
life and destruction and it's just
unimaginable but i don't know if banning
players from playing tennis is helpful
one way or the other sergey i want to
end with you uh because you've gone back
you've retired earlier this year you're
now you've joined the struggle
what is life like for you in ukraine
in ukraine kiev is getting better first
two weeks from brutal honestly now the
key of going back to the melody because
there's no other way but in general uh
until the 9th of may i think is going to
be the main time where we will see
what's going to happen because russia is
planning to do a full scale
um
i don't know colin arms i would say i
don't know how it's called in english
and then
unfortunately for many of us who have
been put back into research most likely
we'll have to go back to active duty so
the next two weeks are going to be
crucial and we just hope that the world
will stay at one piece that it is
well we wish you all the very best
sergey to you and your family and indeed
to all ukrainians uh martina i just
wanted to ask you quickly before we let
you go about boris becky uh someone you
know incredibly well
uh who's now in prison i'm an
extraordinary fool from grace
yes um boris had had some really bad
advice and then he made some really bad
decisions and uh now he's paying as high
prices you can i just hope that he'll be
okay and then he'll come out all right
on the other side
my heart goes out to him and his family
he made some really bad mistakes um and
you know he's paying for him dearly so i
just hope he'll be okay it is an
extraordinary situation isn't it i mean
i know boris quite well uh i have a
interview the first interview with his
wife lily tomorrow actually on this show
uh it's a it's a tragedy for them
obviously a lot of people don't feel any
sympathy for him i think that he you
know he
he did what he did and he committed
financial fraud and he should pay his
price but he was such a an idol in the
sport of tennis it just seemed
extraordinary he's now behind bars
yeah i think the first time it happened
i think i don't think it was his fault
as much as it was of his advisors but he
got let off uh because of who he is and
but because of which i think they paid
more attention to what he was doing and
then the second time it happened it
definitely was on him it seems from what
i've been reading
uh he should have been smarter than that
but uh you know he didn't hurt anybody
he was just trying to save his own
property but that doesn't excuse
obviously uh shirking taxes etc so it's
just uh
you know as tennis players we depend on
other people to tell us what's right
what's wrong lawyers uh cpas etc i've
gotten some really lousy advice over the
years nothing illegal but uh you know
lots lots of money because you depend on
these people to do their job so you can
do yours um not to excuse what what
boris did and again he's playing dearly
and
i just hope his family survives it
intact and most of all boris does
because uh yeah it's this is this is
really rough
yeah well said well lovely to talk to
you thank you very much indeed
thanks chris
and nice to talk again to sergey that we
lost the connection at the end we wish
him and his family all the way back
unsensitive next china's zero kobe
policy shows well zero humanity as most
countries are getting over living with
the virus how long can china hold on
that's next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
millions of people in china are still
living under the world's most draconian
lockdown measures the face of the
country's brutal zero kobe policy
continues to emerge in this footage of a
man in beijing who sealed himself into
his car because he feared he might have
the virus residents in shanghai have
staged screaming protests from their
homes
[Applause]
well robert lawrence
who's a long time adviser to chinese
leaders i'm the author of how chinese
leaders think joins me now welcome to
the show we haven't got much time i'm
really sorry but if you can just explain
to me
how long can this go on this zero cover
policy in china given the reaction from
the people there and can it work
it'll go on for the rest of the year
through the 20th party congress which is
probably in november it's important to
understand three reasons why the
lockdown policy is in place first
putting people first is the leadership
president xi jinping the party's highest
objective their mission and saving
people's lives is the top of the list
estimates were that there might have
been 200 million cases 2 million deaths
in china if they hadn't done the
draconian lockdowns in the early days
secondly because of the early success
with the original
virus
china has claimed that their system for
putting people first is the best in the
world better than the western liberal
democracies so that puts a marker down
on
on the street third the the 20th party
congress for people not familiar with it
is the most important event in china's
political calendar occurs every five
years it establishes the leadership the
top people which in china is the most
important aspect and china needs
absolute stability especially in beijing
until that time so i don't expect any
changes from significant lockdown
they'll try to modify it a little bit as
we see in shanghai as they can but no
significant changes until after the
party congress and after that there will
be and has to be a relaxation of the
zero covet policy just to keep the
economy going robert thank you
brilliantly articulated it's a
fascinating situation there and i
appreciate you joining us sorry no more
time i appreciate it thank you
well forget the fun police it's time to
worry about the speech police i'm afraid
[Music]
well internet search giant google is
rolling out a new inclusive language
function that helps people avoid using
pc words one of the problematic words is
mankind apparently to give you some out
there i don't idea how ridiculous this
is before i play the most famous tv clip
in history i now have to issue a trigger
warning
[Music]
here's the clip
it's one small step for man
[Applause]
sorry mr armstrong offensive triggering
you're going to get banned next
okay that's all from me uh for tonight
tomorrow i'll be joined by boris
becker's wife lily for her first
exclusive interview in the meantime
whatever you're up to make sure it's
uncensored
[Music]
biggest issue in britain right now
undoubtedly is cost of living it is
energy and all that goes with that
inflation look you know i don't want the
government to do very much step back
from most of our lives you know there's
a point when you say actually these guys
are getting a grip somewhere along the
line you want
to believe that the system that is meant
to be running things the chancellor the
prime minister they're going to somehow
step in and make life just a little
easier for the average person
[Music]
talk tv news at nine
good evening i'm zoro suleiman uefa has
banned all russian football clubs from
participating in european competitions
next season they also say the country's
bid to host the euros in 2028 and 2032
is not eligible
madeline mccann's parents say it is
essential they find out what happened to
their daughter ahead of the 15th
anniversary of her disappearance
tomorrow kate and jerry mccann posted on
facebook speaking of their need for
answers after what has been a very long
time
and in a talk tv exclusive a stalker
claiming to be a priest was allowed into
barracks by royal guardsmen protecting
the queen in a major security breach the
ministry of defense is now investigating
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you